[Musique]
j'espère de marche est un
témoin
[Musique]
allégations et qui protège
que des voitures vous avez vu la voiture
de thaler et moi je me penche même pas
frère alan nan nan à la tap que des
voitures depuis thales
note que dévoue à deux chiffres et moi
je ne sais même pas de rôle on y regarde
on
fait quoi they made man die l'accueil
d'un coup wesh
pasqua jacques bascou chef
et puis malade
et il est malade oui c'est tellement
faux riches de me dire allez moi un des
gages aux marchés d'un marché baddou
marché chinois oui oui oui
tout le monde va sauter tout le monde
vole sauter un muret et tma tout le
monde va sauter la canebière est
invendable que des voitures l'artiste r
ce qui se passe